World Championship match class so I
guess at some point they'll have to have
a different class because there's a
finite number of rope championship
matches right so I looked at the list
and strangely my kiss was on the list
but it was the wrong list it was the
hollow notes list but then I found the
chest list and I decided to talk about
Vedic 1960 the first match and I have a
few websites we can peruse before we
look at some of the games now as most of
you know bad Vinick never won a match
where he was the world champion never so
he was the world champion he lost her
drew and then when he lost he would get
the the rematch so the other guy was the
world champion then he'd win this went
on for about seven matches and then he
played petroawski on and that was the
end of that then he just lost and then
he retired then he said how great he was
okay so anyway his first match with tall
tall one second match Bob Vinick won of
course we look at the tall maps that's
all won but the funny thing about it is
I've read a lot of chess stuff we not
now years ago and there's lots of
excuses if you want to be a good chess
player you have a good excuse otherwise
you know so the excuse given for tall
white all got crushed in the rematch was
that he was sick because he was always
sick so he was always sick it's true he
would often go to the hospital during
tournaments often he was born sick sort
of like by missing the joke up here who
was born sick here you do oh sure oh
sure yeah there you go come on man
take me to church all right so anyway
it's always born sick and he had he was
the claw hope it's the right hand these
fingers were together she had like three
fingers on one hand and he always smoked
awake asleep or
he smoked yes okay so he died young and
there are pictures of Saul on the
internet where it looks like he's about
107 and he's like 50 yeah he didn't look
good now went all wasn't sick oh he
always was man he played good now
Botvinnik his excuse was that you know
he didn't play well the first match the
second match Bob but he plays like
Botvinnik and then he just tore through
tall I don't know they're probably about
the same strength they both want all
their games all the time so they were
going to top
they were always top three or four in
the world when they were good now one
thing taunted the Bhavna didn't do it
Saul became world champion in 1960 1979
I visited Montreal with my family to
watch Montreal 79 it seemed like a good
idea and tall tied for first with Karpov
with 10 out of 14 and tall was the
highest rated player in the world that I
think and he was not as young as he was
in 1960 so it's always pretty good and
my last time that I actually I saw it
all after that but the last victory of
tall in 1988 I was at the World Chess
Festival in Saint John New Brunswick
like most of you have been and it was
cold it was February it was cold how was
it cold like I can I'm sort of cold now
and that was 1988 and I still can feel
it
anyway they had a world blitz
championship and everybody played Karpov
played Kasparov played those are the
weak players ok there was a knock out
the final match was tall Vogon young and
tall won every game in the final finals
and Karpov and Kasparov knocked out
Karpov played Shirazi in the first turn
that was hilarious little great pairing
because sparring got knocked out by kyo
georgiev
Walter brown was there well everybody
says they're great until they play
people were better than them Americans
who like to say they're great Walter
brown yes sir Sir why max de loogie
they're good blitz pliers but greats
like Fischer that's that's great tall
Anand went on was good not now obviously
not now yeah he's great anyway
Sarah Wan played a match with Karpov
here a couple years ago then in the
Blitz portion I did Sarah why do I
forgot he he also forgot and Karpov was
like 300 years old and he's he took 300
pieces
ya know Karpov was a good blitz player
cuz Farah was a good blitz player
Fischer was yeah right then they play
blitz in it yeah okay
so anyway if you read the website here
chess Gamescom they have an article why
do know they had articles on this match
and they said tall was waiting the
candidates and he was winning there's
all knows and he was winning the Soviet
championship and boffin is world
champion so it seemed like a good match
and tall just crushed him and there's
the if you could see the bottom there
twelve and a half eight and a half tall
was always in the lead he was up three
games to zero lost two in a row and then
he won three more so six wins to two and
21 games seems like that would be the
better player until they played again
and he wasn't a better player okay and I
guess if I had to like pick which excuse
I like better I mean it's all being in
the hospital every day I would guess if
he wasn't in the hospital he was just
better but now some people think he was
an unsound player those people are
probably right and but people couldn't
prove it so okay so that was a nice
article now Tom wrote a book on this
match tall by Vinick by tall C and it
got really good reviews five stars five
those are the bad reviews
you should see the good reviews yeah you
could buy it on Amazon see you could put
on your Kindle okay and yeah anyway it
was a great match and secured tall's
place in history as one of the greatest
players ever and back in the 60s the
Soviet Union had some good limbic teams
all world champions on every board and
those were the weak players yeah they
didn't want to let Botvinnik on the team
you know you're no good
he's like I'm the world champion and the
hair like all right he has a good
argument yeah I mean they have Petrosian
and tall and Cara's and Smith Slav and
Spassky those are some good players I
mean so and then Gallery was beating
carpa
Fischer every game so I gallery was
pretty good too so yeah they so those
teams somehow won won the Olympiad I
don't get it anyway okay so let's let's
get to the get to the the board here
well that didn't do it all right there
we go
now the first game I want to look at it
has no chess value but it's very funny
that's more important okay and this is
the game I remember as a kid when I was
a kid I was reading all these books you
know San Antonio 72 and then all the
tall books all his World Championship
matches and New York 1924 I'm sure you
know that book really well okay and this
game stuck out at me because it's always
thinking if I play this move they're
going to see what a terrible player I am
he was thinking that while he was
playing the game we played it anyway
okay and it was a Carol Kahn which I
read it was a Carol card I guess and
tall played the two knights okay there's
the two knights okay Bishop to g4 which
is the main move now now Bob the Nikki
pledge opening pretty well I'll give him
that
and give little gameplay terrible no
okay and after h3 you can either play
Bishop h5 or Bishop takes f3 this should
be h5 is a very long complicated
tactical line probably not a good idea
against all so he took on f3
and you guys are confused why I'm
pausing and what did he play would I ask
you if that's what he played yeah there
you go yeah G takes f 3 oh yeah wait
didn't you know how to play chess and he
won this match too he's the world
champion well I mean I think if Liam was
annotating to him he would say just
kidding hey G I'm just kidding Queen f3
nobody plays GF 3 before after this game
but he wanted to get Bhavana god of his
prep and like throw him off sometimes
like for example I've played a list of
Melek Hina twice and I still have zero
first came I was +4 that wasn't enough
after the games told me how bad I played
and then I was like but I was winning
anyway second game she made a bad move
on move three or four and with white and
I was like I'm going to show her and
then every move I made was terrible I
lost
maybe that's what Saul was thinking he
was thinking of my game with Malik Kenan
hadn't happened yet you know tall was
thinking I'll play GF 3 and Bosman toe
that move and I mean I it's just
terrible I can't I mean I can't but I
mean it's funny that he played it knew
how terrible even he knows it's terrible
he knows what's up so it's sort of funny
that he played it okay so yeah usually
don't Bluff in chess because it's sort
of a perfect information game you can
see the board then what sometimes you do
okay so II six solid d4 and okay double
pawns in the center I mean he four is
protected so if the Queen had taken
black would be taking on e4 now getting
rid of the e4 pawn and White's ready to
replace it sort of like if you were
dyslexic and we're playing in ENSO
Indian you know or you're one of the
typical players of the chess club and
you couldn't tell the difference you
know you sometimes you have doubled C
pawns and you're defending your Center
and they've doubled F ones
okay and it's sort of similar I guess to
the Bronstein Larsen variation of the
caro-kann where you play GF you what
what yeah okay so I don't know it looks
like it's a chest position now sort of
boring yeah not really I mean it's sort
of a BA fictitious in at all position
seems like black has a better pawn
structure white has two bishops always
play King b1 yeah this isn't like my
earlier election they both Castle
queenside yes IV white had nothing this
game and was lucky to draw I guess and
then both sides had Perpetual will check
so that's good okay and they agreed to a
draw because perpetual check although I
think you know black was better that
game for most of the game and white
probably got lucky to draw but that came
I remember as a kid and I was like gf3
I'm like talk about some witty stuff
about it like yeah I know this is bad
but it's not as bad as you think and
still nobody plays it so and it sort of
reminds me of you know the fish are busy
our game which I'm sure you're all aware
of where he plays nine h3 instead of
Knight f3 and the two nights and then
you know he's like yeah it's okay it's
fine it said it was good so sometimes
you just get your phone off in the
opening it's sort of funny to do when
you're ahead of the match and you're
playing for the role championship to
play sort of crazy like that but okay
now when I look at the games for the
World Championship and it stopped I'd
Vinick I want to see a Kings Indian
where it's all was black and since I
know my EC Oh codes this looks like one
okay it's all had the black pieces it's
better be this better be a Kings Indian
come on play d4 okay there you go good
now against the Kings Indian really even
players today play it but bhavan ik like
to play g3 Bishop g2 which was played
this game
and a lot of players nowadays when
they're playing the Kings Indian and
they're faced with the system instead of
playing d6 they'll play 6 and d5 and try
to equalize and some kind of neo
grünfeld but okay this is tall's not
doing that toss playing the Kings Indian
one of the reasons tall was so beloved
by everybody especially Julian is he
played to win with both collars and he
played four interesting positions he
never really played the safe move so he
thought if he understood the position
and cannot calculate his opponent then
that's what he should do and a lot of
people especially nowadays I think less
of the 60s and 70s are very results and
rating oriented which is not good okay
so what happens is you got the crazy
parents which is all the parents and
they have their kid play chess and they
want their kid to be higher than the
other kids and if they're not then
they're very upset why is my kid 1300
and that kids 13 20 so we got to get
them high rated okay so they do anything
to get their rating up and if you can
draw a higher rated player and be lower
rated players and get chess lessons and
play higher rated players your rate will
go up and then the parent is proud and
then when you're older and your parent
doesn't necessarily tell you what to do
anymore
then you have to get I am in GM norms I
have to be an I am now I can't wait a
year I'm going to play in 37 round
robins and get three norms then had to
be a GM and so people are very result
oriented now if they're not an IM by the
age of twelve then a GM a age of
thirteen you're finished okay now these
days they didn't really do that there
weren't a lot of GM's fewer GM you were
like top ten in the world so a lot of
players wanted to actually like play
well and win like Fisher and tall so
they played well when they won and they
weren't thinking if I get plus three
I'll win the tournament man Fisher Hall
didn't think that they were like I get
plus twelve in this thirteen round event
well that's that's good score okay
so they were playing to win every game
sort of like Americans do in these swiss
a--'s like the million are open right
now and you got to win a lot of games so
the best american players like nakamura
and so then they win a lot of games
because you're going to win a lot of
games so it's nice that in some round
robins like the Sinquefield cup you know
the players are actually playing for a
win and not hoping to get +1 now a funny
aside they were explaining after the
event that carlson had a terrible
tournament and that nakamura finished
great and tied for a second but they got
the same score anyway but yeah so
somehow it was a great event for one and
terrible for the other they wanted to in
the world I don't get it okay so so
tall's like I'm playing the best moves
I'm playing to when I'm playing
interesting chess and more important
than playing the best moves because
anybody can do that is I'm trying to
make my opponent play badly so if I get
positions they don't understand
they'll play badly and I'll play well
okay that's a good mix nowadays a lot of
the top players I won't mention any
names like I need Gary they'll play
twenty or thirty moves of theory and
then if you do a draw okay and then they
get one win and a draws thinking five
rating points okay I can't imagine tall
you know in his 20s for example having a
tournament with 80 or 90% draws
I can't imagine on each Gary not having
any or 90% draws like imagine tiny
security played in the Sinquefield cup
and had one draw no he's a good player
I'm just saying he could have like plus
one but he can't do that he doesn't do
that he plays on two musafir and they
agree to a draw okay so that's why it's
a little bit more fun to look at games
that were played a long time ago when
they didn't play 30 Musa theory and it's
also good to look at games where the
players aren't quite as good although
not Wednesday nights bad but and there's
there's some there's some happy medium
somewhere okay okay because I a lot on
Wednesday nights that's that's my crying
night um there was a game that was so
bad I did believe
I just said this didn't happen there
people that you would believe it
happened I still didn't believe it yeah
like whoever the worst of the worst
we're worse than that yeah and like I
like these rooms didn't happen I know
they didn't that's how bad they were
yeah anyway we're to film here anyway so
what you'd like is some happy medium
where the players are both trying to win
and they don't play 35 moves of prep and
agree to a draw and that's why matches
that were played in the 30s 40s 50s 60s
when Fischer was playing when Kasparov
was playing when Murphy was playing
these games are really interesting
they're the games are interesting now
for the most part but sometimes they're
not
okay then again I don't want to be you
know talking about a tournament where
80% of the games were draws it doesn't
mean the players are playing better now
they are but a lot of it has to do with
the players attitudes okay and luckily
tall had the right attitude
okay Knight bg7 and even nowadays if
there's a match with the top five
players in the world and leave just pick
two of them and it's a world
championship match they're all going to
be happy when they draw a black like if
Carlson's black against the non it's a
draw he's like great now I get why it
and I'm okay I mean and that's not what
happened you know 60 70 80 90 years ago
they play for a win Fisher Fisher wasn't
Fisher wasn't playing for a draw with
black again Spassky okay but nowadays it
would be like unheard of if they didn't
if they weren't happy with the draw
they'd be like wow I drew with black in
ten moves all right I get white so okay
let's see if things are different all
right
okay so castles be v e4 this is still
theory today a lot of people today are
playing
nine to c6 and they're not playing e5
and they're playing some other crazy
variations panel variation what's that
yeah he said yeah okay but this is ill
this is a long time ago when they're
playing fun they just play d5 okay yeah
nowadays a lot of people think this is
too passive for black but generally what
happens is some kind of spring like
nothing happens nothing happens nothing
happens
like the movie I always make fun of what
is the movie exactly pay attention in
class next time and then all of a sudden
things happen and you're like wait
nothing happened 421 was why don't they
calculate now so blacks a bit passive
because of his pieces over here yeah but
they'll get out later okay so d5 the
Depot is under some pressure takes takes
right c5 91 typical typical Botvinnik
okay so Bob - could the maneuver is
night around and while he defends the e4
pawn okay
you incorrect ones I need one-on-ones on
detail I don't think it's going to stay
on either square think when you played
92 you were going to keep it there now
were you yeah that's what I thought you
were going to do well the I D one
defends d3 more and probably on c4 and
Queen a6 your knight has to do something
I don't think there's anything wrong
with Knight d2 unless 93 is good but I'm
too old for that
but in Mutsu old maybe just 93 is good
okay so now you won
no more 93 93 politics happy now for the
lower rated players which is all of you
and all of you at home you guys don't
like this as much as the high rated
players do higher rated players love
having upon on d5 then they have what's
called space and their opponent can do
anything so Bob
pretty happy and the night on c5 was a
pretty good night and now it's not there
the knight on f6 yeah where's the not f6
going Julian
yeah I don't know either the bishop on
g7 where's that going no so yeah so
white has a lot of space and White's
going to slowly do this
magnus carlsen style but marvin exile
okay and what black doesn't really have
compensation for this space blacks going
to play for tricks but tall is going to
play for tricks so there's me a lot of
tricks okay so Rick c8 taking the C file
now in a lot of Kings Indians white
plays on the Queen side black plays for
me as in for example Wesley so Hikaru
Nakamura from last month and then when
black wins it's really cool and when
white wins white gets like three Queens
this is the opposite Black's got nothing
on the Kings side but black has a queen
on b6 black has an open C file black's
bishop on d7 is controlling the Queen
side so blacks to the plan the Queen
side okay Rigby one question you can
play 90 in an f5 but I don't see how
you're going to attack me you know
sometimes you play knight h5 and Queen
g5 and h5h we I do any of that I think a
lot of times in the g3 Kings Indian
that's just not happening
you're just you're not getting there's
no checkmating attack and since the
Queen's I'm b6 there's no reason why
white can't plan the Kings side also
King h2 f4 or just take the pawn on f5
and then blockade and if black did play
98 and f5
I'm not thrilled with his night on e8 so
I would have to probably go back to b6
yeah perhaps 6 I mean yeah that's taking
a long time I'll play Bishop e3 and
you'll be like no good and that's
another plan and you would think that
would be the kind of plan that
tall wood use and in these kinds of
games in the g3 Kings Indian tall did
something I like quite a bit he didn't
do nothing
ok that's always my recommendation of my
students and then eventually he did
something when you were lulled to sleep
so obviously anybody can move the night
and play f5 but he'd move around and
around and around then he would do
something active and you'd be like what
you can do anything exit 420 emilie's
what are you doing ok so I like that
style of playing also waiting and so
Bhavana gets in time trouble ok rubber
b1 very safe move he wants to play
Bishop e3 but after queen's eggs b2 the
knight on c3 is hanging so rugby one
first
see now you're happy you get to play now
h5 and f5 Bishop e3 queen goes to b4
that's a tall move I would go to DA guys
I'd be afraid Queen goes to e2 and the
problem is if black plays f5 which he
probably played then when I take it it's
hard to take back your nights hanging g4
forks you so Queens who sort of against
that hits the night okay rook c4 that's
a tall move rook c1 Rick c8 so yeah
black is realizing the center is closed
and a lot of times where I have black
and queen pawn openings I'll also close
the center and then my opponents like
why is the center closed this I'm not I
don't play these positions then you
maneuver on both sides of the board and
try to gain an advantage and White has
an advantage in space in the center but
Saul's done a good job of taking the C
file and if he doesn't lose his Queen
he's sitting pretty okay it's to
paraphrase to super paraphrase chief
Wiggum
wow that was a paraphrase okay so King
h2 which does nothing so I like it f5 so
you like it
each takes f5 so I like it which rule
does that follow Julian
he takes out five it's a very specific
rule no well I always play King bee ones
not happening here all right now G takes
f five is risky because of Queen takes
Knight so he didn't do that
okay Bishop takes and the rib goes to
a-1 and eventually Y might play G for
win apiece hey when that happens so
Knight f4 before you go into piece you
sack of peas okay and you can argue that
tall could calculate a million moves
ahead he figured everything out but I
think a lot of his calculation was based
on justification of based on the
position for example black has a very
active position his rooks are better
than White's rooks his Queens better
than whites Queen bishop on f5 is pretty
good so it makes sense to continue to go
forward and it's likely to sacrifice
will work and if white doesn't accept
the sacrifice you have I mean the
Knights going to g3 if taking the bishop
on g2 okay so we have to take yeah now
it's hard to play Wyatt
I guess if Bishop d2 b2 is hanging but I
mean that's what I would do
hey okay cool I play like I play like
the guy who was alright and queen bee -
and so I was right on all accounts
normally when you play Queen beat sue in
any position in chess when you're black
the guy plays rugby one but there's a
bishop on f5 so now it's hard to play
rugby one because it's hanging on the
other hand this Knights attacked so many
times I can't count that I yeah so
that's a lot of attacking going on yeah
so somehow black got very active on both
sides of the board and he's pushing
Botvinnik around it wasn't easy to push
around
no wonder they would pull my own Olympic
team terrible now he did well you know
who did even better than Bhavik the
Olympiad and those Olympiads was was it
was Petrosian and that guy G he was
getting like like when he playing
regular turn
to see if like 15 draws but then the
Olympiad then he would beat everybody
and he was like cause a gold medal
okay so rugby won anyway because I don't
know what else to do
your Knights hanging your bishops Bend
okay f3 breaking my rule f3 that's
called no yeah but no yeah does not
deflection but decoy and deflection and
move the defender and a fork it's every
it's everything well the thing is the
Queen is defending the bishop so if the
Queen takes on f3 it's not defending the
bishop and I want to open this diagonal
to White's King and open this rank for
the rook yeah everything rook takes
Queen
well obviously Queen takes Queen takes
is just blacks winning Bishop takes
what's what's his what's his angle I
mean looks terrible for white but just
terrible and then play then play Queen
c2 that's just terrible I mean it's just
terrible I mean every piece is hanging
okay so he played rook takes Queen pawn
takes Queen blacks down a piece but that
knight on c3 doesn't look too good
Lonnie - looks pretty good okay rugby
three defending is Knight rook d4
attacking the bishop that's defending
the knight Bishop defends everything
Bishop e5 check the ship f4 man it's
tough for white White's up a piece but
his pieces aren't - good night take c2
that gets rid of the pawn Knight takes
and what if he takes these just down
material yeah
always play Bishop f1
and black got his piece back and he's
still very active and obviously boffin
ik is in terrible time trouble f4 looks
terrible yeah the two bishops are too
strong that's pretty nice tricked by
Botvinnik Bishop takes Knight rook III
check drawing chances well if you draw
he might probably not d5
Bishop h4 check yeah okay
man time to resign now he resigned
I thought you resigned earlier but yeah
that so that was a typical tall type of
win
Kings Indian complications and when
Bhavana gets in time trouble he falls
apart and again for certain players like
Nakamura and who rad you live as he put
the Kings in he's the only one right
yeah the Kings Indian the computer says
it's bad then you win
well sometimes you lose but that means
sometimes you lose when you play chess
but that's okay and when you get games
like this where black is very active
black sacrificing material and whites
basically falling apart on both sides of
the board you get to see what a great
player tall was I mean the rematch
wasn't so good these things happen
okay lots of drawers of course there's a
very long wind which is reminding me of
the queen of pawning they had I don't
know if this is the game when I was a
kid there were certain games I
remembered ok so here's another tall one
this time he's white and again
tall was known for a wild crazy
attacking chest
but even though players are known for
certain ways of playing that doesn't
mean they always play that way again
that's something lower rated players
have an issue with is they're usually
very dog man
and the better you got a chest the last
dogmatic you are okay like Julian you
know make some move in resins too
dogmatic okay and you can't move or
reason I can't do either one
you're good play like Chris like you
don't do nothing you sit there in the
game end somehow so even though certain
players when you think of them let's say
Karpov you think boring technical skill
but I'll show you checkmating a taxi
head like against course nine the dragon
in 73
you agree 74 it was one of them we don't
know I'm talking about
I've lectured on that game and also like
Petrosian who was known as a boring
player had brilliant Queen sacrifices so
tall who's usually playing e4 and
playing sharp Sicilians if possible is
playing Knight f3 g3 which is what
people play now but I mean you could
play any what you want
okay and you can do whatever you want
yeah b3 94 and it will play this way now
okay we're transposing into some funny
Grunfeld
I think I've actually had white in this
position I mean black I think if I'm
really and I agreed to a draw we tied
for first it was a weekend tournament
another one's we need it well this was
born yet okay house black okay so this
looks more like a Banach position than a
tall position and in World Championship
matches usually the players are about
the same strength so sometimes a player
has a certain style he prefers so like
in the last game in the King's Indian
Bhavana got his space advantage tall got
an attack on both wings and then sacked
apiece and ended up out calculating him
in the early endgame this seems like a
real Botvinnik position well there's not
going to be a lot of tactics it'll be a
slow positional game and yet tall was
the one who outlasted them
these positions are very hard to play
for black black in these positions a lot
you just sit around don't do anything
which I like to do you don't do nothing
when you do something that's wrong
so look who did something right he
didn't play Queen b8 probably as a pawn
or something so he took this and you
never want to do that
unless you have some great tactical
justification because you're giving away
the center blacks tactical justification
usually be something like c5 but with
Bishop takes b7 coming I don't believe
it so I don't I don't believe any of
this I believe nothing yeah I mean this
is just good for white white has the
center to bishops Botvinnik Botvinnik
Botvinnik how could you do that
the a bishop c1 now we're playing chess
well now Bishop f4 Bishop g5 the next
move Wow Queen II hate if you guys get
better at chess you'll play who's like
Queen a no you're better than me then
how would I know
yeah well he was worried that Bishop f4
would pin his Queen
Nigel's Queen but I'm still not playing
Queen a it ok provoking a move you
should never play never play f6 and I
think this is especially true here
because then I think the e6 pawn is a
bit tender come on play about vidiq I
dare you yeah i rikiei that's right ok
Queen d2 yeah this is just how awful for
black okay so a lot of times people
don't like to lose slowly where they
have no play so they lash out so
obviously White has a better Center to
pawns in the center why does the two
bishops black's queen is on a 8 black
can't put a rook on d8 if I was a
betting man that you showed me this game
if I was a betting man and you showed me
this game and you said this is tall
Botvinnik what colors were they this is
this is Bob predict all for sure this is
pure Bhavana with
White Knight f3 g3 slow to bishops
better center but it's it's top out
Vinick so it's amazing how sometimes the
rules are reversed
occasionally Karpov would check make is
far off just usually usually not usually
Kasparov would have the attack
okay so f5 and again that seems more
like a tall move but Bothell neglect
like to play the Dutch very strange for
world champion okay Bishop age six Queen
and Bishop better than Queen at night
nice blacks Kings a little iffy okay now
we're going to go to work on the e pawn
now I was making fun of the Knights
players and rightfully so you read Annie
yep and he's like but I was playing the
only me alone and I played over I just
say not sated the games today tell what
I did yeah and there was one game I know
this was a given one of my students he
played f5 and a similar pawn structure
and the guy rerouted his Bishop to b3
yeah then that was it as e six was was
permanently weak as I've highlighted
here the other guy played good all right
so it's halls decided to attack the e
pawn rook f7 so what happens on Queen
takes do we play my favorite move
yeah are you talking
yeah because Queen and Bishop Queen at
night it seems like White's pieces are
all working this Knights working to
defend that yeah okay so rookie f7
defense Queen d2 defending the d4 pawn
always plug this ship f12 PI Bishop c4
of course always play he takes out five
and it's always a good player yeah yeah
this isn't good for block yeah the Queen
of Bishop really crushed the Queen at
night here as they usually do yeah that
Knights not Emmeline the Knights going
to stand c7 forever defending e6 and if
the knight ever decides to come active
the e6 isn't isn't looking so good Queen
back to D - that's like Karpov chomsky
1992 when your openings yeah an e6 of
the long run is not good okay you can't
play Knight takes Queen because rook
takes Queen check ah he moved towards
the e6 pawn but didn't take it yeah
blacks King isn't so good he defends the
e6 pawn anyway a sevens hanging and a
little nice little tactical trick that
Julian would have played in one second
looks like King h8 loses energy 7 losses
what did he do because the game went a
long time may he defends good what would
you play because calling to play Queen
d8 check no matter what you play all
right Queen d8 check rip takes rook I
guess ya say there was a queen of
planning in this one of these matches
and this game was really long so that
might be this one so it was this game
now what famous game does this remind
you of
yeah I'm kidding Fischer Spassky 1992
didn't see that coming
Fischer was two pawns up with a queen
upon any we could didn't win then I was
like looks like I not play chess for
twenty years that came wasn't in the
movie yeah that was two pawn sacrifice
all right so yeah so White's up two
pawns he's having fun can't have more
fun than being up two pawns and here
there was a resignation yeah well two
pawns up winning and checkmating is
winning everything's winning yeah so
that was a very bad Vinick like
performance from tall but I mean that's
what you get yeah
now unfortunately occasionally Bobby
Fischer was right okay it happens if you
say a thousand things one or two of them
are right so Fisher didn't like the fact
that if you were headed a match and the
match was limited you would draw than
you win the match in like that he said
this man should go at least a year okay
which almost happened man you're not old
us remember but Karpov cos far off the
first match that's still going on I'll
let you know when it's over I'm trying
to figure which is going to be first
that match will end or this sandwich
over five and a half years ago from
coffee charts all's gonna be ready it's
tough tough to say exactly sure yeah how
much quicker yeah anyway yeah if you
lived in st. Louis you get that joke
anyway so as the match ended it went
draw draw and the match was over because
it was the first to get twelve and a
half points and once Pavlich was ahead
by enough he could he could draw fact
even though these games that he won near
the end didn't he could have drawn them
and he would won the match in 23 games
okay
seventy yeah well I think at that point
he's up where Bhavana cast to win games
21 22 23 and 24 that's not going to
happen like it's me it might but not a
good name not I guess the guy who's
beating you yeah so that's unfortunate
but that's that's the nature of a match
that's limited okay and it's again
Tawes white and look what he's doing
he's like let's make the game boring and
this is actually very funny
because a lot of people are like chess
is dead look at all the drawers well
when the players want to play like tall
about Vinick then they play and then
when tall is like hey it's Rob wins be
the world championship then he can play
like the guys do now okay draw it's like
what are you going to do so this is why
Petrosian in particular was a very tough
World Championship opponent because that
guy could draw so if you want a game you
were in trouble on the other hand if
he's playing in a round-robin with the
10 best players in the world he's not
going to win and he did not win because
he'd have two wins and nine draws that
doesn't win although it does now but it
didn't then and and when Petrosian
played World Championship man she had to
beat him and then somehow Fischer beat
him every game four games in a row so
okay anyway probably ba ba panic had
sort of given up by this point and tall
just play whatever the most boring
simple trade everything like the would
they play now yeah except this was to
draw to win the World Championship now
now to Magnus Carlson's credit we needed
to draw to become the world champion for
the first time he played for a win
because he was better then he didn't win
this better at position yeah okay black
never going to win here he's going to
lose her draw so Bob Vinick offered a
draw and I was like alright I'm a world
champion okay yeah but okay I mean
blacks I mean black has to play for a
win he plays the most passive boring
trading everything opening see now
Fischer was black orcas para or Carlsen
or somebody who knows they have to win
you're four in a row it's not going to
be a Queen's Indian we trade everything
you well maybe you're the world champion
every day but this made in the world
champion well that's one argument I
think Carlson wouldn't take a draw here
he'd be like wow I have a good position
yeah like I can't have zero losing
chances and I'm better yeah
and Tom's like I'm the world champion
time to go drinking and then he's like I
lost the veil change if time to go
drinking so yeah occasionally he was
drinking he smoked more but it was close
yeah close tough decision yeah so anyway
this match was great because it's all
this reminds me of basically Kasparov
Karpov their first match with the style
class except man Kart you weren't alive
man Karpov showed him after nine games
it was four to zero after 29 games it
was five to zero and then that was it
but I mean yeah he I mean in this match
Bob verdict didn't show his strategical
mastery was better than tall's tactics
second man she did and with Karpov
because part of it was the opposite
Karpov showed his positional mastery was
better than Kaspar his tactics and after
second mansion on it was either even or
orcas para gotta buy a point or two
that's that's that's correct and you
would think since it's always like five
years old here he would get better
it's always the younger player but it's
all got crushed the second manager is
destroyed like sort of the same as this
match and this clash of styles I think
makes a good match where one guys a
better strategical player like Karpov
was to Kasparov and Kasparov in taller
better tactician z' and you get like you
get to see tall play G takes f three and
you're like what and you get to see
Kings Indians and when you have
unfortunately for this you guys when you
have Carlson and nog you don't see that
you see like I'm slightly better no I am
and then draw draw draw
Carlson's better jockey Constance better
and then he wins 2 to 0 with a trois ok
but here you see fewer draws and some of
the draws for example just because you
have them up here ok
72 moves 41 41 76 and only at the very
end you know ok match is over yeah I
mean they're they're playing a limited
number of games and Fischer didn't like
deaf issues like let's just play until
somebody wins some games not just draw
drugs on the world champion then
unfortunately the arguments made against
Fischer's plans are correct the way the
players play now if you did that that
match might never end I mean if you play
first to win 10 games I mean the
eighty-five match would still be going
on I mean they have five games the three
after 49 games I mean you can't you
can't be playing like nine months and
he's like yeah why not so I don't think
spectators want to see nine months of
two guys playing I could be one I don't
want to see an anon play Carlsen for
nine months yeah I want to see I want to
see that yeah but but yeah I mean in my
opinion the world championship managers
now are way too short you know twenty
thirty games okay not like ten games
twelve games come on that's not even at
sunny chess at all thirty games is a lot
but you know there's some there's some
happy medium I don't know what it is
let's go get paid a million dollars for
a match they can play for a month
million dollars a month is okay it's a
pain to pay cut but they'll take it yeah
okay anyway so well for those of you
showed up late which is some of you Bob
McNair one of matches the world champion
he always lost her drew and then he
wouldn't rematch next until he played
Petrosian just kept losing yeah and
Bhavana played a lot of World
Championship matches he played I don't
know maybe he's seven or eight of them
and he played Bronstein plates me Slav
played Petrosian played tall and when
you play so many World Championship
matches
that really gives you the advantage over
the other guy who's just playing one and
then when you beat him in their Eman
she's done it Sevilla gets a beat them
to benches hard to be bothered like to
imagine she's pretty good right
so the system is a very is very strange
and has been for a long time and it's a
little strange now because the World Cup
which determines to people go to the
candidates matches is like blitz chess
like two games of slow chest that we
it's like Ben Simon's running it
actually true game match or then you
play like 15-minute yeah come on
so no the final match is usually some
pretty good players Carlson and on those
guys are pretty good yeah but no yeah in
the final when you have cardiac and
smooth ler they're not playing for who
goes to the candidates exactly very
suspicious